[Music]  we got a surprising six-year time jump  yeah okay we got we got the script it  was awkward yeah it was an awesome  surprise for us oh yeah but before we  knew it we were shooting in it the  biggest surprise of all Clark survived  somehow are we gonna be getting any  flashbacks to see how she survived the  death storm yeah I think it's suffice to  say that we're gonna all have to you  know have some sort of animation  explanation for what's happened over the  last six years so yes I think it's safe  to say there will be there will be  flashbacks of my sort of experience and  perhaps these guys as well know that you  guys haven't started filming again and  you can't reveal too much about the next  season because this guy sitting over  here with the sniper rifle oh but can  you tease  can you guys tease which character you  think has changed the most over the time  jump like the five year thing yeah  yeah